[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as we make way for the chargers running
back
austin eckler uh austin thanks for
joining us before
i get to you i gotta ask this question
with the day nuts all right we do this
occasionally how much do you think
austin eckler
can bench todd i'll start with you i'm
gonna say 325.
25. mclovin 3 30.
30. seton uh no offense 310
3 310 not a good reaction from austin
there where i just saw that
uh paulie he's yoked i'm going 375. 375.
i was going to go 375. i will go
380 for austin eckler
uh what's the most you've benched okay
so the most i've ever
maxed with 3.85 hello winner winner hey
there you go dad
right there winner winner chicken dinner
i don't know we've been in a while
but uh i mean i could bench 315 probably
four or five times right now so
whoever's at 310 i'm i'm hurt a little
bit
is the is the 40-yard dash important
like the time how important is that well
you were undrafted
how important did you think it was uh
for me i felt like all my numbers were
very important just because
i think people were trying to as far as
scouts were trying to find what the heck
made this guy go to division two you
know was it some physical attribute or
was it like maybe some mental or like
what the heck happened
so for me i felt like it was the most
important thing at the time when i was
going through my draft process
it was just my 40 time to show that i
could run at this level too
but also there's no pressure on you but
there is pressure if you were
a high draft pick and went to the
chargers
or that you're just trying to make the
team like which one would be more
pressure filled do you think i think it
comes down
to the individual you know i put i put
as much pressure as anyone could ever
put
there's no one that could have put more
pressure on me than i put on myself
and that's because i knew the importance
of the opportunity and it really meant
everything to me
and i was making sure that i was all in
on the moment
and so i think it it's situational
uh my guys want to know if you have trap
implants like like like it looks like
herschel walker
those are real those are not implants
right yeah
this is a straight straight body right
okay all right don't make me clean
don't make me take off my shirt this
isn't a competition here austin that's
not what we're doing here
uh speaking of rivalry how much of a
rivalry do you feel
with the rams i don't feel any rapidly
with the rams
um i can't focus on the rams i have too
much to focus on with the charges and
trying to build the community with us
and so i don't even spend one moment my
mental time thinking about the rams
you you never think about the rims
you've never gone hmm
what did the rams do no i mean the only
time i would ever think about the rams
is if it's like hey do you guys want to
do a community project together since
we're in the same stadium same area
okay that's not exactly trash talk
no no no no i'm not trying to chat i'm
trying to
i'm trying to build here cleaning up
trash might be but that's not exactly
trash talk there
does anybody ever talk junk to you
during a game
um no not really not usually
um i mean i'm not out there talking junk
either i mean
i'm out there you know having a good
time um
playing football trying to make plays
and so i mean i'm not
if someone's talking to me i'm not gonna
just let him push me around bullying me
um but for the most part nah it's pretty
clean
i was wondering that when you first got
to the chargers you wore
the number three in pre-season and i'm
wondering with the single digit
are we going are we going back and going
back to the roots
what do you think ae3 what do you think
you know i don't think i could do it uh
one for one i'd have to buy all the
inventory from the jerseys from the nfl
which i'm not doing
and then uh two i've kind of established
myself as you know number 30 on the
charger so
i'm gonna stick with it okay all right
fair enough uh what was it like first
time you met philip rivers
um you know it was kind of just that
that moment like hey man like
you may have seen i felt like these guys
are legends here like you know there's
been people that have been playing
forever people that are wearing my shoes
and so it's kind of
kind of just made it more real to me you
know it's something that you see on tv
all the time but
now i you know being around these guys
and been around the league for now and
it's like now it's like
more normalized and so that's kind of
what being around him when i was around
him
just around the team in general you know
um
it just felt like surreal and i was
super nervous all the time i remember
being in my first huddle i threw up
like i literally had to come out of my
first hurdle because i was so nervous
because i cared so much i literally had
to come out and went through it behind
everyone
wait wait wait wait wait wait what did
your teammates think is this
normal that guys get nervous and you
know barf in the house
probably not it wasn't in the huddle i
literally was just feeling sick and i
just pulled myself
out and then it went through it behind
everybody
now philip rivers said the first time
that he met you he had all of his
children there
oh yeah and you didn't realize that
they were all his children right right
yeah i was because i was walking
like it was like after practice and the
day was done and i was just like walking
through and he just had all these like
little kids with him
you know i knew nothing about i was know
and then i just kept walking and i was
like damn you see phillip like
he's got like some type of like little
group with him like maybe like showing
him around the facility or something
like that
i was eating lunch like now someone's
like no that's his family man i was like
no
like wait a minute what like there was
that many kids there was
too many kids though they must have some
friends or something he's like no he's
got a lot of kids i was like oh my god
i thought he was literally just doing
like a little meet and greet like some
some of the youth from the
from the area or something oh my god uh
do you care
are you gonna watch the draft uh i'm
gonna watch the first round
and then i'll keep up with who the
chargers pick up because that's who i
really care about as far as you know
what's relevant to me
when did you know that uh justin herbert
was for real
shoot probably his second or third game
in when he continued to make plays
um you know after his first game it was
like okay like this man showed some
talent and showed that he can actually
run out here and
you know hang with uh with you know the
best of them you know we played
the chiefs his first game we were up by
15 points you know and then
holmes did his they brought him back in
but um
after those first three games like this
guy is consistent and he's making plays
you know he's
smart with the ball he's making plays
with his feet and throwing it down the
field
um because we couldn't tell we couldn't
tell in training camp because we didn't
have any preseason we didn't have
um you know any like live reps live
situations so
you don't know really what a guy has
until it's like hey the pressure is all
the way turned on
so yeah he's like but he's very low-key
very chill yeah right i love that i love
that man i love it he's just you're
ready to come in ready to work
wants to come and hang out with the boys
and play play some football yeah
you go from phillip rivers who was fiery
and yelling at everybody
so phil wasn't yelling everybody just on
game day he was yelling at
everybody mainly the raps and mainly the
other team
well uh good luck have fun uh tonight
with uh your event the gridiron gaming
group draft day event
nfl players athletes celebrities
reacting to their team's draft picks
twitch.tv austin eckler
and the stream begins at eight eastern
tonight austin great to talk to you
thanks for joining us
awesome thanks for having me on dan
that's the chargers austin
eckler a lot of fun and some good
stories there